hey guys how's it goin so today we're
gonna we had a little busy day today
it's actually not that busy but I am
preparing for VidCon which is coming up
this week and if you guys want to know
my schedule I'll put a link in the
description where it'll have everything
that I'm doing where you can find me so
I'll be there Thursday Friday Saturday
ready to turn up hold on
green light as I was saying VidCon it's
here I can't believe it's here already I
feel like I was just there but I've got
a really fun day of errands to run
I have ants at my house thankfully
they're not in the house but they're
outside and they're like circling the
perimeter and I don't know what to do so
I'm gonna I'm gonna add that to my to-do
list of things today to figure out how
to get rid of those little pigs
really well so far I bought four black
t-shirts but that's it four of the same
exact black t-shirts and so this is this
is gonna be a really great outfit of the
day for VidCon I'm kind of freaking out
so my favorite bag they have it in pink
this brand called zadig & Voltaire and
I'm slightly losing my mind because baby
I I don't even know of a store in Los
Angeles the last time that I went to was
in Paris you walk away something I don't
need okay I'm okay
no I'm not really sure about the sweater
it's like what are you oh excuse me
what are you I just made a really big
mess so I whatever happened today I'm
not even sure what happened I think I
got some clothes for VidCon but I
decided tonight to make a couple of
cooking videos I'm on my second one
right now and I wasn't recording because
I was cleaning up and I put the house I
called the Vitamix top on but the top
wasn't actually on and as I was going to
do like it's cleaning cycle it exploded
everywhere and I'm so pissed I wasn't
filming because it was an absolute
disaster
volcano of water erupted from the
Vitamix so that happens I'm gonna go now
it's almost 1:00 a.m. and I've destroyed
this kitchen so well see you later
so did you guys that I remember
yesterday which was the previous clips
that you're gonna see in this video well
I said I bought four black
well teachers are fantastic but I got
the wrong size and they're really
they're really small I feel like I'm a
sausage inside of a sausage casing and
I'm trying to escape so I need to go get
different size t-shirts that was very
much everything that I planned on
wearing to VidCon so I'm gonna do that
and then picking up a People magazine
because this week I'm in their magazine
so I'm gonna go check it out take a
little peek give you guys a little a
little sneak peek of it and if you guys
post a picture of you with the magazine
I will uh I'll face I'll like hashtag I
don't know it's a hashtag I just seen
people maybe so finally on our way to
VidCon when I was talking to Jenna about
what she got for VidCon yeah come here
this is amazing like we're we're clearly
the same person pretty much hey what did
you buy - where - VidCon today oh I
bought okay so I bought four black
t-shirts and three white t-shirt but
they already know what I bought I bought
four black t-shirts also oh I think
they're all v-necks black t-shirt four
core of them the same exactly the same
I'm excited to see you guys all of the
info again is in the description where
you guys can see me this weekend we're
turned up to Martin garrix
on this trip
yeah yeah miles
you too late cause I think it's not a
good work high five south toward Santa
Anna st. Anna there's a roller coaster
oh it's right where Disney we should
begin to train you
more than hoses turn at Disney laughter
I've ruined laughs on your phone
oh yeah no totally you don't I lost
everything on my thumbs
I'm so hungry
here we are at VidCon 2015 let's go back
and watch 2001 was the first one I don't
like ten I'm a little sweaty I hope no
one sees me I'm sweating let's turn it
up out here everyone actually you know
what I hope they don't do they I hope
they don't leave my car on again for
three days my suitcase weighs probably
75 pounds I didn't bring anything about
I talk like teacher I've hacked in seven
minutes and I we made it we're here Jen
VidCon 2015 the party is starting well
actually it's not starting at all I'm
gonna go to bed but I'll see you guys
tomorrow
peace out